so today i'm going to be trying
blindfold chests
i've got three very strong opponents
behind me
i'm going to try and play them all at
the same time this is one of the most
difficult things you can try in chess
i haven't practiced i'm not sure how
it's going to go i'm very nervous
it could go well it could go very badly
as well oh gosh
okay let's do this guys okay
board one knight f3 for two
e4 or three d4
world one e6 um
c4 for two d6
okay um for two d4
c4 castles rook to d1
knight to f5 42 e4
do you mean e5 correct
uh knight g to e2
board one pawn takes c4
queen takes c4 like to
f8
have you been studying simon williams
dvd
e6 knight to d5
knight to g6 knight to e5
bishop to d7 queen to c7 bishop
takes knight f5 r2 bishop f4
knight f4 right okay knight
f1 rook a to d1
oh rook a to d1 sorry
a to c1 sorry to c1 sorry c1
oh this is hot rook a2c knight takes
b6
what did you say knight takes b6
i hope that's legal and that takes knife
wait one sec you played queen c8 yeah
queensland um what's up
where's that night 95
but earlier you said knight b6 right
a6 uh okay oh sorry sorry sorry
yeah uh i was getting confused with
another position sorry my bad
uh bishop takes g7
d6 okay this one knight takes b6
earlier i was thinking different boards
this doesn't look good but the queen two
d7
queen g7 checkmate yes good game
okay thank you thanks for two queen two
e7
oh that must be a win here
um okay queen to g6 check
to s8 to d7
[Music]
rook from a8 to d8
i play rook takes e7
[Music]
okay all right
um okay
and black resilience
thanks again thank you bishop e3
yeah black results
whoa that's bright yeah
i need to lie down now i need a drink